ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
[inaudible]
EYES BEGINNING.
I CAN SEE THAT WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE ENOUGH FOR A
QUORUM -- SORT WILL BEGIN AS A
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE THE VICE
CHAIRS AGREED -- TO TO ALLOW US
TO GO FORWARD AS A COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE.
I DO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO
ARE AUTHORS OF BILLS TO A COME
ON DOWN -- WE DON'T WANT TO MISS
YOUR SPOT IN THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
AND LET ME JUST MENTION THAT
THERE ARE ELEVEN BILLS ON OUR
FILE TODAY. THREE OF THOSE BILLS
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
THAT'S FILE ITEM. EIGHT NINE AND
TEN THOSE AUTHORS HAVE GOTTEN A
MAGIC TICKET.
POSSIBLY.
SO OUT OF THOSE ITEMS WILL BE
TAKEN UP ON THE CONSENT FILE --
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR HAS BEEN
PULLED THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING I'M GONNA
SUGGEST THAT WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM. TWO WITNESSES IN
FAVOR IN TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF THERE ARE ANY THAT
THEY BE ALLOWED.
TO HEAR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
TO FACILITATE THE NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WE HAVE ON THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
TODAY.
IS THE LAST HEARING FOR OUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS SERRA
HUCKLE.
WHO IS SERVE THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
[inaudible] FOURTEEN YEARS.
THIRTEEN IT FEELS LIKE.
FIFTEEN BUT SERRA WE WILL MISS
YOU AND WE WISH YOU WELL IN YOUR
FUTURE ENDEAVORS.
I HAVE DONE GREAT WORK FOR OUR
COMMITTEE.
WE PLAY BEFORE I WAS HERE -- AND
WE APPRECIATE IT WE APPRECIATE
IT VERY MUCH SO WE WILL MISS YOU --
WILL MISS YOU GREATLY.
AND SO MY FRIENDS THAT -- THAT
ALLOWS US TO BEGIN I SEE WE HAVE
A WONDERFUL AUTHOR WHO IS HERE.
SHOULD HAVE ALL THE PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR IMMEDIATELY UPON
HIS ARRIVAL.
SO I WANT TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN TO THE
COMMITTEE.
YOU HAVE ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE AND WE WELCOME
YOU. TO OUR OUR PLACE OF
BUSINESS TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN RECOGNIZED
THAT I PROBABLY SAID WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL AUTHOR HERE AND I GOT
WORRIED THAT OKAY I'M A LOOK
LIKE A FOOL IF YOU'RE REFERRING
TO SOMEONE ELSE SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR
HAVING ME.
COME UP IMMEDIATELY I APPRECIATE
IT I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT ONE
IN FIVE WOMEN.
THAT WILL BE AFFECTED BY
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER
LIKE POST PARTUM DEPRESSION.
HOWEVER TRAINING -- FOR BEES
ISN'T YET AVAILABLE FOR
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATIONAL
CHOIR MINTS AB EIGHT FORTY FIVE
WOULD ALLOW MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE COURSES
REGARDING A PREVALENCE RANGE OF
MATERNAL.
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT OPTIONS
AS PART.
OF THEIR CME REQUIREMENTS HERE
WITH ME TO TEST FIND SUPPORT IS
CRYSTAL MCCAULEY I REPRESENTING
TWENTY TWENTY MOM.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
HAVE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL CALLING I'M A MOTHER
REPRESENTING TWENTY TWENTY MOM A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHOSE
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT OF MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS.
LIKE POST PARTUM DEPRESSION.
ALONG WITH MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH NOW WE ARE A CO SPONSOR
OF AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS ARE THE LEADING
COMPLICATION OF CHILD BIRTH
AFFECTING UP TO ONE IN FIVE
WOMEN.
MANY DOCTORS ARE HESITANT TO
SCREEN FOR THESE DISORDERS DUE
TO A LACK OF KNOWLEDGE IN
COMFORT LEVEL IN ADDRESSING THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF THEIR
PATIENTS.
AB EIGHT FORTY FIVE WILL BUILD
THE CAPACITY OF DOCTORS TO
ADDRESS MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS.
BY URGING THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION SKEWS ME
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
TRAINING ON THIS TOPIC.
MORE AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE.
THE BILL BUILDS UPON AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE WHICH REQUIRES
OBSTETRIC PROVIDERS TO BEGIN
SCREENING FOR THESE DISORDERS
STARTING NEXT MONTH.
AND AB THIRTY THIRTY TWO WHICH
NEXT YEAR REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO
TRAIN THEIR STAFF AND INFORMING
PATIENTS ABOUT THE SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF THIS RANGE OF
DISORDERS.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I KNOW
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN WHO SUFFERED
UNNECESSARILY FROM DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY DURING THEIR
PREGNANCY OR AFTER THEY HAVE
GIVEN BIRTH.
MANY OF THEM DESCRIBE REACHING
OUT TO THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER ONLY TO WAIT FOR WEEKS
OR MONTHS FOR REFERRAL BE
PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS THAT
MIGHT HAVE MADE THEIR SYMPTOMS
WORSE OR SIMPLY HAVE THEIR
CONCERNS DISMISSED.
MAKING AVAILABLE TRAINING ON
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS.
TO DOCTORS SERVING IN THE
PERINATAL POPULATION WILL
PREPARE TO HAVE PROVIDERS TO
EFFECTIVELY SCREEN TREAT OR
REFER FROM ETERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS.
AND WILL INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT PREGNANT AND POST PARTUM
MOMS RECEIVE TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE CARE.
CONTENT FOR CONTINUING EDUCATION
WHICH INCLUDES DIAGNOSIS
EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING AND
OPTIONS.
AND BEST PRACTICES IS WIDELY
AVAILABLE THROUGH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE COUNTRY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB.
EIGHT FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
CRYSTAL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES -- IN FAVOR
OF WHEN I COME UP OR COME TO THE
MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
BE IN SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION AND
COMMENT ANY -- BUT YOUR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR
ARCHULETA THANK YOU FOR SHARE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT -- ISSUE TO US -- CAN
GIVE ME AN IDEA OF THE LENGTH OF
TRAINING WERE TAKEN WHO WOULD.
BE THE SUPERVISORS INSTRUCTORS
HOW HOW COULD WE PERCEIVE THIS
TO GO FORWARD AS YOU INTENDED TO
GO TO BE PART OF THEIR CN
CONTINUE IN EDUCATIONAL PROMISE
SO FORGET IT.
FOR FOR DOCTORS AND LAWYERS
OTHER PROFESSIONALS THE THE THE
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE SET FORTH --
BY THE OPERATOR THE GOVERNING
BOARDS SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS WOULD
BE AN AVAILABLE CLASS INSTEAD OF
TAKING A CLASS ON WHATEVER ELSE
THIS WOULD BE AN OPTION
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WELL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL TO US IT
IS.
SO INTERESTING THAT IT AT A TIME
OF GREAT JOY AND EXPECTATIONS
THAT -- THAT SO MANY -- OUR OUR
CHALLENGE WITH THE OTHER OTHER.
WORRIES CONCERNS ALL THE SAME
TIME MANY ADDED THREE VERY REAL
AND VERY -- IMPACTFUL AND IN
SOME CASES IN A VERY NEGATIVE
WAY AND I APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS THAT HAVE YOU
BOTH IN BRINGING THIS TO US AND
IT CERTAINLY HAS MY SUPPORT.
THE COULD AS A SUPPORTER OF THE
MINORITY SIDE AS WELL.
SO WHERE SHE CURRENTLY IS JUST
SHORT OF A QUORUM WILL HAVE ONE
IN A FEW MINUTES AND LOOK FOR TO
MOVING YOUR BILL AT THAT TIME
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR BEING HERE.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN IS
HERE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING ON TIME AND
WE WELCOME YOU. TO THE IN P..
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL. NINE SEVENTY
THREE AND WE WELCOME YOU AND AND
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF
YOUR MEASURE.
MISTER CHAIR AB NINE SEVEN THREE
CLARIFIES THAT COMPLIANCE WITH.
A UNITED STATES PHARMACOPEIA
NATIONAL FORMULARY IS A BASELINE
LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE FOR THE
COMPOUNDING OF DRUG PREPARATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA.
CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR DRUG
COMPOUNDING ARE CRUCIAL FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC.
SINCE UNSAFE COMPOUNDING
PRACTICES CAN LEAD TO INJURY AND
EVEN DEATH.
THIS BILL HAS ZERO OPPOSITION
AND HAS THUS FAR RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY --
WITH ME HERE IN SUPPORT IS MERRY
JOE DOUBLE LEFT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
WELCOME.
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN FOR AUTHORING AB.
NINE SEVEN THREE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS CONSIDERATION.
THE BOARD IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY CHARGED WITH
REGULATING THE PRACTICE OF
PHARMACY.
THE BOARD'S VISION STATEMENT IS
HEALTHY CALIFORNIANS THROUGH
SAFE QUALITY PHARMACIST CARE.
IT IS WITH THAT BASIC TENET THAT
THE BOARD IS SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION THIS MEASURE
INSURERS THERE IS A COMMON
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT AS PART OF THE BOARDS
REGULATION ASSESSMENT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH NATIONAL
STANDARDS WILL BE MEASURED.
AS A CONSUMER PROTECTION AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE REGULATION
OF ALL AREAS OF PHARMACY
PRACTICE.
THE BOARD BELIEVES BOTH
CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES ARE BEST
SERVED WHEN THEY'RE IT'S CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PRACTICE
EXPECTATIONS.
pCONSIDER CONSIDERATION HONORING
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN C. JOHNSON WITH NIELSEN
WORKS MORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AND CARDINAL HEALTH
ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE BOARD.
VERY GOOD.
THERE ARE OTHER WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COME IN RECOGNIZED
THE RECOGNIZED FOR THE RECORD IF
THEY COULD COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
THIS POINT TIME.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHERS IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS -- COULD BILL.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHERS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BRING THE MATTER
BACK -- TO THE COMMITTEE.
I DO KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'VE TAKEN A QUORUM
IN JUST A MOMENT TO LET ME SEE
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON THIS BILL.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT FOR JUST A
MOMENT.
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE A ROLL CALL
AND SEE IF WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUAN FIRST.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
CHING HERE TO LET US.
SUCH A LETTER HERE DOT.
DOT HERE GALGIANI NOT YOUNG HERE
HELLO.
HILL HERE LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE
PAN WELL.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
I DO OUT ONE RECOGNIZE THAT
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY -- SENATOR
LEYVA.
WHO IS MOVE THE BILL SO WITH
THAT -- WE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHANG.
CHANG AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN WILL.
ARE THE BILL CURRENTLY ENJOYS --
SEVEN VOTES BUT WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OF CONTRAPTION
MEMBERS THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH
FOR COUNTY SENATOR GIVE THANK
YOU.
FOR A MEMBERS WE HEARD THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY FIVE
VICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
A FEW MINUTES AGO.
AND THEN THERE IS A MOTION NOW
ON THE ON THE TABLE BY SENATOR
HILL FOR THAT MEASURE.
WITH THAT THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL MISSION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA PARTULA EYES
DOT.
I GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN WILK.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILL I DOES ENJOY
F. MAJORITY SUPPORT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
I DO SEE TO AUTHORS HERE I DON'T
KNOW WHO ARRIVE FIRST OF ALL.
THE FOR HANDS UP NOW OKAY THE
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL -- FOR
FOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- MEMBERS THIS BILL
IS A BIT OF A CLEANUP BILL WITH
THE BEER OF CANNABIS CONTROL
JUST TO ENSURE THAT TESTING THAT
GETS DONE.
IS NOT THAT THE TESTING IS DONE
DISTRICTS STANDARD BUT IS NOT
GONNA GET CAUGHT UP IN MINISTRY
LEE BECAUSE OF TYPOGRAPHICAL
ERRORS OR MINOR ERRORS.
IN THE TESTING SO OFTEN THOSE OF
LEAD TO RETESTING AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE.
JUST NOT CONDUCIVE.
TO THE BUSINESS THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING SO THAT'S
REALLY ALL THIS BILL DOES AND I
ASK.
ANY WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANY FRANK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB FOUR ZERO
FOUR A CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
THAT ALL CANNABIS AND CANDICE
PRODUCTS DISTRIBUTED AND SOLD IN
THE STATE -- BE ACCOMPANIED BY A
CERTIFICATE OF THE OFFICE OF
ANALYSIS A COA.
CERTIFYING THAT THEY'VE BEEN
PROPERLY AND ANALYZED BY TESTING
LABORATORY UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT ALLOW FOR TESTING
LABORATORIES TO CORRECT ANY
ERRORS WANT THAT C. O. A.'S BEEN
SUBMITTED -- THIS PROCESS DOES
NOT ACCOUNT FOR COMMON HUMAN
HAIRLIKE TYPOS AND OTHER --
ABSOLUTE ACT ACCIDENTAL MISTAKES
I'M IN THE PROCESS AND THIS
CAUSES BOTTLENECKS IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN THIS BILL OFFERS A SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION -- BY
ALLOWING TESTING LABORATORIES TO
SUBMIT A FORM TO CORRECT SUCH
MINOR ERRORS.
FURTHERMORE BY GRANTING THE
BUREAU THE ULTIMATE AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE WHAT SORT OF ERRORS
MAY BE CORRECTED WE'RE MAKING
SURE THAT OBJECTIVE DATA
RELATING TO A CANNABINOIDS
CONTAMINANTS AND OTHER THINGS UP
REMAIN.
ON IT ALTERED -- THIS ENJOY
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NEITHER
THANK YOU GOOD THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF
OF NOR CAL CANNABIS WERE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS NOT
SEEN ANY.
CENTER RELAVIS MOVE THE BILL.
CALL FOR THE ROLE ON THAT.
HOW DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
OKAY.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI
GAJI ON THE AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY THE AYE PAN HI PAN AYE WILK.
WE GET THAT BILL ENJOYS MAJORITY
SUPPORT BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY IS
HERE LIKE TO WELCOME HIM TO
COMMENT PRESENT ITEM NUMBER TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOR TWENTY THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS.
OF I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT A BEFORE -- TWENTY I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS BILL.
WORKS FOR THE CENTER AND FOR
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TAKEN A FEW MOMENTS BUT
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL.
REMAINS THE SAME TO GIVE
AUTHORIZATION TO THE CENTER OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS RESEARCH. TO
CONTINUE PERFORMING NECESSARY
RESEARCH ON THE POSITIVE OR
NEGATIVE EFFECTS.
APPEAR CANNABINOIDS ASSOCIATED
WITH COMPOUNDS.
IT ALSO BROADENS THE SCOPE OF
RESEARCH AVAILABLE TO CMC ARE.
AND WOULD ALLOW THEM TO THE
ABILITY TO CULTIVATE THEIR OWN
CANNABIS.
IT'S CRITICAL TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE CURRENT CODE
TO ALLOW FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE
STUDIES IF WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE.
THIS NEW AND INNOVATIVE FIELD OF
RESEARCH FOR OUR STATE.
THIS BILL PRESENTS RESEARCHERS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE HEALTH BENEFITS.
THAT CAN BE GAINED FROM THIS
PARTICULAR SUBSTANCE AND WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE.
DOCTOR TOM MARK ON HIS CO
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
MEDICINAL CANNABIS RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO IS GOING TO SHARE SOME
MORE ABOUT THE RESEARCH YOU NEED
FOR THE BILL [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
SO.
SO JUST VERY QUICKLY BY BY WAY
OF BACKGROUNDTO THE C. M. C. R.
WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
TWO THOUSAND WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THE COMPASSIONATE USE ACT --
CENTER VASCONCELOS SPONSORED A
BILL TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE.
OF RIGOROUS SCIENTIFIC DATA
REGARDING CANNABIS AS POSSIBLE
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE A FAX.
DURING THAT ERA WE GOT SOME
FUNDING TO AND DID SEVEN
CLINICAL TRIALS THE FIRST
CLINICAL TRIALS IN TWENTY YEARS
THE SMOKE OUT OF US -- AT ALL OF
THEM SHOWED POSITIVE RESULTS IN
VERY SHORT.
TERM STUDIES BUT IN THE
SUBSEQUENT TWENTY YEARS A LOT
HAS HAPPENED WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT CANNABINOIDS INTO
CANNABINOIDS THE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT MIGHT BE USEFUL --
BUT WE CAN'T STUDY MOST OF THOSE
BECAUSE OF VARIOUS IMITATIONS
AND APART WE ONLY GET.
OUR PLANT MATERIAL FROM BAIDOA.
US THE ONLY SOURCE AND ONE OF
THE THE GOALS OF THIS IS
ULTIMATELY SPECIALLY WITH
FEDERAL WHEN FEDERAL APPROVALS
COME THROUGH THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH EITHER INDUSTRY ARE WITH
OTHER UNIVERSITIES. TO DEVELOPED
CANNABIS PLANTS THAT MIGHT BE OF
INTEREST MEDICINALLY.
OFFER VARIOUS CONDITIONS.
ANOTHER LIMITATION THAT WE FACE
IS THAT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
SOURCES OF KIND OF CANNABINOIDS --
IT'S HARD TO LOOK AT CERTAIN
CONDITIONS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
STUDY GOING TO LOOK AT AUTISM.
BUT WE HAVE TO GO TO A SPECIFIC
SOURCE TO FIND CBT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE TÁEEN AS A TNC IS THE
PSYCHOACTIVE COMPONENT.
OBVIOUSLY WE DO NOT WANT TO GET
KIDS STONED AND HIGH -- SO THIS
ALSO ENABLES US TO BE LOOKING AT
THESE SYNTHETIC CANNABINOIDS IN
THE INTEREST OF SAFETY AND DOING
CLINICAL STUDIES TO UNDERSTAND
HOW CANNABIS AND ITS
CONSTITUENTS MIGHT AFFECT.
OUR PERFORMANCE.
AND THEN I'LL JUST ALSO THROW IN
THAT -- WE DO STUDY ALSO LOOK AT
PUBLIC SAFETY I DO DRIVING
RESEARCH AND SO FORTH IMPACT OF
OF CANNABIS -- AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LIMITED BY BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN.
THE CANVAS THIS BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO THE PUBLIC -- AND
THIS WILL ENABLE US ALSO TO
ALTERNATELY LOOK AT THOSE
MATERIALS AS WELL.
AGAIN ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX TOURISM
ME OF EASE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY FRANCO THE CALIFORNIA
CANNERS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SOARING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. FOUR
EIGHT I DO I RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUE SAYS.
SOMETHING OVER THERE IS A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS -- IN A
ANALYSIS ARE YOU TAKING A LOOK
AT THAT AND ARE YOU WILLING TO
SUPPORT THAT YES WE ARE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU RECOGNIZE
SENATOR PAT.
I THANK YOU AND SUMMER LIKE
DOCUMENT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AYE I THINK
WHEN THE MOST FRUSTRATING ISSUES
WHEN IT COMES TO CANNABIS AND
RELATED -- THE ISSUE.
WELL I THINK TERMS A MEDICINAL
CANNABIS IS ACTUALLY LACK OF
INFORMATION SO AS A PHYSICIAN.
I SEE.
NUMEROUS CLAIMS BEING MADE ABOUT
CANNABIS SOME THE MORE
QUESTIONABLE I'VE ALSO SEEN
NUMEROUS CLAIMS INTO BOTH IN
TERMS OF ITS BENEFITS BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF ITS DANGERS.
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY WE NEED
ACTOR INFORMATION ACTUALLY MANY
OF THE TREATMENTS POSITIONS
EMPLOYEE -- WE CAN TALK ABOUT
RATE OF WILL AIDS.
TO AT THE OUR VARIOUS OF LIGHT
OTHER THINGS HAVE BOTH POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE EFFECTS RIGHT AND
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THEM SO WE
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO
BENEFIT PATIENTS AND HOW TO
BENEFIT THE PUBLIC AND ALSO
PROTECT THEM FROM.
THE DANGERS THAT MIGHT BE
ASSOCIATES WELL STRIKE THAT
RIGHT BALANCE.
AND SO TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND SO I APPRECIATE WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO.
I GUESS ONE THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
MAYBE -- FOR THE START BY
GETTING YOUR NAME RIGHT NOW MORE
CONTACT OUR MARKET YES IS IS
THAT -- SO UNDER THIS BILL I
MEAN WE HAVE FUNDING WE PROVIDE
FOR CANNABIS RESEARCH ARE WE STE
DOLE CONSTRAINED BY THE FEDERAL
RULES OF WE USE ONLY STATE OR
PRIVATE FUNDS.
IN TERMS OF THE THEN SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW -- OF A BILL
APPROPRIATE SAMPLE OUR OUR TRIO
THAT SUBSTANCES FOR AND THAT YOU
KNOW EXACTLY POTENCY AND PURITY
AND ALL THIS OTHER STUFF.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
CONDUCT YOUR RESEARCH ARE YOU
STILL IF YOU'RE NOT USING
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THAT RESEARCH
ARE YOU STILL CONSTRAINED -- BY
SOME OF THE FEDERAL RULES VEAL
CONDUCT THE THE RESEARCH THAT
YOU NEED TO DO -- SO CURRENTLY
WE ARE AND PART OF IT IS IS SORT
OF MAYBE PROBABLY A SUBURB OF
PEOPLE BEING RISK AVERSE TO THE
THINGS ARE DECADE OF THINGS THAT
COULD HAPPEN -- SHOULD WE USE
CANNABIS THAT THAT COMES FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO POSITION
OURSELVES READY TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT AS THINGS START TO
LOOSEN UP AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL I
KNOW THERE A LOT OF BILLS
CURRENTLY MAKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH.
THE TO GIVE MORE FREEDOM TO THE
STATES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
RIGHT NOW -- WE HAVE TO GET OUR
OUR CANNABIS FROM NIGHT A IS IT
A SIMPLE CHOICE SO JUST TO
CLARIFY AND I'VE BEEN AND I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE WITH
THIS BILL IF THIS BILL IS PASSED
AND BECOMES LAW [inaudible]
WELL THAT.
ARE YOU WOULD YOU STILL HAVE TO
WAIT FOR FEDERAL ACTIONS FOR YOU.
TO DO TO BE ABLE TO DO THE KIND
OF RESEARCH THAT YOU NEED TO DO
OUR WILL THIS BILL IN ITSELF
ALLOW YOU TO DO MORE THAN YOU'RE
ABLE TO DO NOW.
I SUSPECT WE STILL NEED SOME
FEDERAL ACTION SO RIGHT NOW IT'S
WRITTEN INTO THE BILL THAT WE
STILL WILL FOLLOW THE D. E. A.
GUIDELINES -- BUT AGAIN IT DOES
POSITION US WELL I THINK -- FOR
WHEN THOSE THIS ENOUGH OR YOU
KNOW I I'M NOT A LEGISLATURE AND
I'M ALSO NOT PART OF THE UC
SYSTEM A WRITER INSURANCE
SHERMAN.
DEPEND ON HOW MUCH THEY ARE OR
WILLING -- TO DAY SORT OF TAKE
THE LEAD ON THIS I CAN JUST ADD
SOMETHING WHAT WHAT THEY'RE WHAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES IT AND ONE OF
THE MAIN FUNCTIONS BILLS TO SHOW
THE PRIORITIZATION.
AND POINT OUT THE PROBLEM IN THE
DISPARITY THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING BECAUSE WERE WE'VE
GOT THE RESEARCH WE'VE GOT THE
ABILITY -- AND AND WE HAVE THE
THE MECHANISM IN PLACE TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY WHAT NEEDS TO
BE IDENTIFIED BUT WE HAVE.
THIS REALLY OLD STANDARD THAT
LIMITS US TO THE POTENCY OF
SEVENTIES WE'D AS OPPOSED.
TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY BEING USED
TODAY AND SO THAT AS A IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I AM FAVOR
YOUR BILL -- BUT WHY I'M ALSO
TRYING TO GET AT I'M TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT.
YEAH I SAID YEAH OBVIOUSLY DE A
RULES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
PROTECTING PEOPLE PATIENTS WE
WANT TO KEEP BUT IF THE ONES
THAT.
BASICALLY JUST STOPPING YOU FROM
DOING THE RESEARCH.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE ALL THE YEAH
WE HAVE ALL THE ARBY'S ALL THAT
OTHER STUFF THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT -- BUT I'M ALSO
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT I'M NOT
SUGGESTING YOU AT EIGHTEEN TO
BUILD AYE AYE I AM I AM TO ME
ABOUT HOW DO WE NEED TO GET THAT
INFORMATION WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
ACCURATE FORMATION SO PEOPLE CAN --
HAVE AND SO THAT AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT VERY SHORT TERM STAYS WE
NEED LONG TERM STUDIES RIGHT AND
SO FORTH SO -- I'M JUST PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION IS REALLY
ABOUT HOW CAN CALIFORNIA LEAD.
YOU KNOW WE'VE NOW THE PEOPLE
CALPERS SPOKE THEY'VE YELL
LEGALIZED THE AREA OF
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO BE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCURATE FORMATION.
IF YOU'RE USING A MEDICINALLY
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THE BENEFITS
AND THE THAT THE RISKS ARE HOW
TO BEST STRICT AS THE RIGHT
BALANCE WE POSITIONS NEED
AFFIRMATION OTHER HEALTH
PROVIDERS.
SO I'M HOPING WE CAN -- WITH
THIS BILL THAT ALSO THINK ABOUT
OTHER ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE TO TRY
TO MOVE THAT FORWARD IN A WAY
THAT WILL BENEFIT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
DESPITE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
NOT I RECOGNIZE SENATOR PANS
MOTION.
AS AMENDED THE FOR THE BILL AS
AMENDED SENATOR.
THE BILL AS AMENDED ALL RIGHT.
NOTHING FURTHER WILL OFFER THE
THE ANYONE IS SAYING CLOSING.
I THINK EVERYTHING.
IS PRETTY MUCH BEEN SET OF THAT
I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE.
THE DESPERATE NEED WE WE HAVE
THE EXPERTISE HERE AND WE JUST
NEED TO NOT TIE THEIR HANDS.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
WELL GOT.
NINE FABULOUS OUT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK HERE.
LIKE TO ADVISE HIM UP. 2% --
ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN THIRTY TWO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO ARE THE ANTI COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND SENATORS.
OF AB TEN THIRTY TWO MAKES A
REASONABLE EXPANSION TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER.
PROTECTIONS REGARDING TICKET
SALES.
OFTEN TICKETS TO POPULAR SHOWS
ARE SNAPPED UP BY ONLINE BONDS
WHICH THEN RAPIDLY RELEASE THESE
TICKETS.
ON THE RESALE PLATFORM SAID
INFLATED PRICES RECOGNIZING THIS
IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
MADE IT A CRIME TO USE BOTS TO
BUY AND RESELL TICKETS IN BULK.
AB TEN THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES
LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW.
UNDER AB TEN THIRTY TWO FIRST
PARTY SERVICES THAT SERVE THE
SAME PURPOSE.
BUYING AND SELLING.
TICKETS INVOLVED WILL ALSO BE
LEGAL WE'RE TALKING NOW FIRST
PARTY LIKE TICKETMASTER -- THE
BILL WILL ALSO MAKE CLEAR WHO WE
ARE TRYING TO PROTECT WITH THESE
LAWS THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS
ATTENDING SHOWS.
THANK YOU ARE YET AT ANY
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SPENT.
YOUR QUESTION THAT JUST A BRIEF
THAT ARE ATTACHED WHAT THANK YOU
FOR READING THIS BILL FORD IS
THE OTHER PREVIOUS BILL TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE -- I THINK
GET ALONG -- WE WE NEED TO TRY
TO BE SURE THAT WE FEEL WE DON'T
HAVE.
PEOPLE MANIPULATE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED FOLLOW
UP ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REGIONAL BELL
AND MY WIFE WHO ATTENDS ROCK
CONCERTS REGULARLY ALSO THANKED
ME -- THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PAN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
I I DO HAVE A MOTION BUT I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE CLOSING
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE --
AT THIS BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION ASPIRO VOTE THANK YOU
WE'LL SEE IF THAT CONTINUES
TODAY.
THE CENTER CHIANG IS MADE THE
MOTION TO APPROVE THE BILL.
THAT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
VIRTUALLY THE AYE DOT.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GAJI ON THE
AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WILK RIGHT OKAY. NINE
REMEMBER YOUR RECORD CONTINUES
THAT'S A NINE ZERO VOTE IN FAVOR
HERE ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
ALL RIGHT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO IS HERE LIKE TO INVITE HIM TO
COME FORWARD. 2% ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF AN MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A. B..
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH
CONFORMITY AFFLECK AGENTS ACT TO
RECENTLY ENACTED RULES OF THE NC
DOUBLE A AB FIVE FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN WILL ALLOW NARAL
EXCEPTIONS. TO ALLOW STUDENTS
ATHLETIC TO WORK WITH A SUPPORT
AGENT.
THE PURPOSE OF AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN YEARS TO ALLOW THE NC
DOUBLE THE RULE CHANGES. TO COME
INTO EFFECT IN CALIFORNIA WITH
ALL POLITICIAN OUR E. LEAD TO
STUDENT ATHLETES.
SO ARE WITH ME HERE WE HAVE A
CHEN AT LOW PATH FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING MRCHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JANET LOPEZ REPRESENT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
WHAT?
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CRAZY
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU.
ENTER MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
LAST CHANCE I WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THE THANK YOU A MEMBER FOR
COMING BEFORE US -- I HAVE A SON.
WHO HAS A SON MY GRANDSON WHO IS
ABOUT TO ENTER INTO COLLEGE AND --
HE'S IN THAT LEVEL ONE
COMPETITIVE EDGE AND SO THIS
BROUGHT A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
MAKE IT HE'S ON HIS WAY --
WITHOUT NAMING THE UNIVERSITY
BUT HE HOPES TO BE THE
QUARTERBACK ONE DAY.
BUT MY CONCERN IS -- THE COST
FEES AND EXPENSES THAT MIGHT BE
SWIRLING AROUND SOME SORT OF
ASSOCIATION WITH A MANAGER OR OR
AN AGENT OF SOME SORT OF THING.
SO WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL HOW.
THESE KIDS MIGHT GET CAUGHT INTO
A CONTRACT THAT.
THEY CAN'T GET OUT OF IF IN FACT
THEY DO NOT GET PICKED UP IN
THEIR HANDED A BILL UPON
GRADUATION.
HAVE YOU LOOKED INTO THAT IS
THAT AN ISSUE.
THAT -- DEFINITELY THE DAILY YOU
WANTED.
TO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TELL.
I'M SENATOR WE ACTUALLY PUT A
PROVISION YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF
FOR THE ROUND DANA MITCHELL I'M
THE STAFFER FOR MISTER.
TO WE PUT A PROVISION IN THE
MOST RECENT ROUND OF AMENDMENTS
THAT MAKES THE CONTRACTS
TERMINATE BY THEIR OWN TERMS --
IF THEY DON'T -- ELECT TO GO
PROFESSIONAL AND AND RETURN BACK
TO THEIR SCHOOLS SO THAT WILL BY.
DEFINITION -- WILL CUT IT OFF
RIGHT THERE FORM SO.
SO THERE THERE WON'T BE ANY --
FEES COSTS AND EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEMBERSHIP
OR OWNERSHIP.
FOR A PARTNERSHIP THAT WILL CALL
IT WATEVER IT MIGHT BE AND THEN
AT THE END DOESN'T WORK.
THE STUDENT RETURNS TO SCHOOL
AND HE'S NOT STUCK WITH THE BILL
OF SOME SORT.
OKAY GOOD THAT WAS MY WORRY
THANK YOU VERY GOOD CENTER
ISOLATING GRADUATION SIGN YOUR
BUDDING GRANDSONS ATHLETIC
ACHIEVEMENTS SO.
SENATOR DODD.
YES BUT CENTER ARE TO LET I
WOULD AT LEAST EIGHT DOLLARS TO
SCHOOL YOU KNOW THE THOUGHT SO
HIGHLY OF YOUR RED SAID -- TO IN
TYSON THAT UNIVERSITY BUT I I'VE
A LOT SO I I MIGHT IF THAT THE
CHAIRS I BETTER NOT.
NEVER THE LESS -- I'M INTERESTED --
MAYBE A DUMB QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW BUT I'M JUST INTERESTED
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFONIA.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
ATHLETES WILL QUALIFY FOR THIS
OVER THE YEARS IN MANY SPORTS.
TELL ME WHAT -- YOUR INTEREST IS
IN SEEING THIS TYPE OF POLICY --
PREVAIL.
SO WE ARE ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE OF
STATE LEGISLATION THAT WILL --
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE RULES
THAT ARE ADOPTED BY OUR
ORGANIZATION NATIONAL THE NC
DOUBLE A AND THIS WOULD REALLY
PUT -- STATE LAW IT CONSISTENT
WITH THE POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BY THE LARGER MEMBERSHIP --
THE NC DOUBLE A HAS THIS IS A
PART PART OF THEIR THIS IS.
PART OF THE NC DOUBLE A RULES
RIGHT NOW WE'RE THE INSIDE WITH
A AN AGENT WHILE THEY'RE STILL
PLAY AS DANA MENTIONED IT'S A
RECENTLY ADOPTED.
YEAH SO WE'RE TRYING TO ALIGN
STATE LAW WITH THE RECENTLY RULE
CHANGES ADOPTED BY THE NC DOUBLE
A MOVE THE BILL OF NOBODY ELSE
HAS.
YET I HAVE SENATOR PAN AND THEN
WE'LL GET TO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THE I.
APPRECIATE -- THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ALIGN WITH NC DOUBLE A
ALTHOUGH I WILL POINT OUT I MY
CONFIDENCE IN NC DOUBLE A ITSELF
IS NOT THAT GREAT AT THE MOMENT --
AS I UNDERSTAND THIS ONLY
APPLIES.
TO MALE ELITE ATHLETES
[inaudible]
BASKETBALL [inaudible]
IN BASKETBALL.
AND SO WIDE BY NO YOU'RE NOT NC
DOUBLE A BUT I MEAN IT'S SO
THERE YOU KNOW OF A ONE AND DONE
RULE WHERE YOU HAD TO PLAY ONE
YEAR OF COLLEGE AND THEN YOU
KNOW YOU CAN BE RECRUITED AND
THERE WAS A GROUP OF FOLKS THAT
WOULD.
GO COMMIT THEMSELVES -- TO TO BE
RECRUITED AND THEY'D SHOW UP AT
THE COMBINE AND THEY WOULD HIRE
AGENTS AS THEY WOULD HAVE TO IN
ORDER TO BE CONSIDERED AND THEN
THEY WOULDN'T GET DRAFTED.
AND SO THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY BUT THEY COULDN'T
COME TO THE COULDN'T COMEBACK
SCHOOL AND THEY DIDN'T GET
DRAFTED AND SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
THOUGHT THAT WAS UNFAIR.
AND THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM TO
SEE IF THEY CAN GET -- FOR THIS
VERY ELITE CADRE OF BASKETBALL
PLAYERS -- DEBILITY TO COME TO
THE COMBINE TO TO TRY OUT -- IN
ORDER TO DO SO YOU NEED TO BE
DECLARED A LEAD BY THE THE NBA
COMMITTEE SO -- LIKELY HAS THIS
QUESTION THAT -- SO THE NC
DOUBLE A HAS MADE THIS RULE
CHANGE FOR A VERY NARROW GROUP
OF ATHLETES -- IS.
SO WHEN -- I GUESS ARE THE
UNIVERSITIES IN FAVOR OF AND YOU
SAID I HEARD WERE PILOT.
ARE THEY IN FAVOR THIS POLICY
BEING APPLIED MORE GENERALLY
EVENTUALLY TO ALL ATHLETES.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
REASON THAT IT'SHAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IN BASKETBALL IS DRIVEN BY
THE NBA'S ROLES ON RECRUITMENT
WHICH IS HOW COME I STARTED WITH
THE ONE AND ROLE -- THE THE
RECRUITMENT INTO THE
PROFESSIONAL RANKS IS ACTUALLY
DRIVEN BY THE PROFESSIONALRANKS
AND SO -- FOR INSTANCE BASEBALL
PLAYERS ARE ALLOWED TO BE
RECRUITED -- BECAUSE THE THE
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL SYSTEM HAS
THE FARM TEAMS -- THEY ALREADY
ARE ALLOWED UNDER THE EXISTING
INTO DOUBLE A RULES TO HAVE
AGENTS AND TO TO BE PART OF THAT --
THE NBA IS -- RATHER UNIQUE IN
THAT THEY ALSO -- THEY HAVE THIS
RULE -- THE W. A. B. A. ALSO HAS
A A RULE SO THEY ARE CONSIDERING
EXPANDING IT RIGHT NOW TO THE W.
NBA AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT SPORTS WHERE
THE PROFESSIONAL SPORTS FOLK.
ARE ALLOWING -- COLLEGIATE
ATHLETES TO TO JOIN THE RANKS
WERE TO JUMP FROM HIGH SCHOOL
STREET IN LIKE THE NBA'S DOES
ALLOW PEOPLE.
SO THAT'S THE THE THE GENESIS OF
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO NARROW IS.
LIKE I SAID IT'S DRIVEN BY THE
THE NBA'S OR DO YOU THINK THIS
IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STUDENTS.
YES OTHERWISE THEY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE.
TO RETURN TO THEIR INSTITUTIONS
WERE THEY NOT DRAFTED.
OKAY SO SO THEN IF THIS IS THE
BEST AND I REALIZE SOMEONE'S HAS
TO DO WITH THAT.
BUT OTHER PROFESSIONAL.
THE X. DO IT BUT THEN THEN YOU
ARE IN FAVOR OF DOING THIS MORE
BROADLY.
FOR YES SIR AND THE LANGUAGE IS
ACTUALLY WRITTEN IN A WAY TO NOT
EXPRESSLY CONFORM TO ONLY THIS
ONE RULE CHANGE BUT WE RODE IT
SO THAT WE COULD ALLOW AS THE NC
DOUBLE A EXPANDS.
THEIR PROGRAM THE LAW IS NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO BE REVISITED
EACH TIME YOU ADAM BOARD AND
I'VE LET ME ASK -- POLLUTANTS
FROM.
USC SO NC DOUBLE A IS.
GOVERNED BY UNIVERSITIES CORRECT
YES [inaudible]
SERVICE.
HUNDRED MEMBERS RIGHT NOW MORE
OKAY BECAUSE YOU'RE MINE SO IS
THERE A COMMITMENT FROM USC AND
PERHAPS I KNOW THAT YOU'RE TO
ONE IS HERE SO IT'S NOT ENTIRELY
FAIR FOR YOU ALONE BUT TO
ACTUALLY A PUSH FOR THE
APPROPRIATE CHANGES AT NC DOUBLE
A AFTER ALL YOU ARE.
THE GROUP YOU ARE RUN BY
UNIVERSITIES I I IF I JUST AND I
I SIGNED A FEEL THAT THE
UNIVERSITY THEMSELVES.
ARE NOT BEING STRONG ENOUGH
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR OWN STUDENTS
AND SINCE THE S. INTERESTING
YOU'RE ADVOCATING FOR AN
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU ACTUALLY
RUN.
SO CAN WE SEE BROADER CHANGES
THE NC DOUBLE A WITH -- THAT
WHERE YOU'RE NOT JUST USC BUT
OTHER CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES STANDING TOGETHER
SAYING WE DEMAND CHANGES AT U.
S. IN NC DOUBLE A FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF OUR STUDENTS.
KNOW ABSOLUTELY CENTER I KNOW
YOU **** THAT QUESTION WHEN WE
ARE IN SENATE EDUCATION.
AND SO I KNOW OUR TIME HERE IS
IN FOCUSED ON THE LARGER
DISCUSSION WITH INTO DOUBLING
GOVERNANCE ABOUT THIS BILL BUT I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT.
WE ARE -- ADVOCATING FOR REFORMS
ON BEHALF OF OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES REGULARLY YET I THOUGHT
I GUESS SO YEAH I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS IS THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO JUST DO BILLS
CONFORM WITH THE NC DOUBLE A I
WANT US TO THINK HERE ART IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ABOUT WHAT'S
BEST FOR STUDENTS.
AND NOT JUST DO THINGS BECAUSE
AND TWO OF THEM EXCHANGED WORDS
CAN CONFORM TO THAT.
ANDERSON YEAH OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU YEAH ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
THAT ARCHULETA SIGNATURE.
I WAS IN THE IMPRESSION THAT
PERHAPS SOME OF THIS WORD THAT
THISINCLUDED WOMEN AS WELL.
AND I WAS ALSO THE IMPRESSION IT
INCLUDED ALL SPORTS AS WELL.
SO I SEE THAT ALL SPORTS ARE
LEFT OUT AND CERTAINLY WOMEN ARE
BEING DISCRIMINATED BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE WOMEN'S BASKETBALL
PROFESSIONAL LEAGUE -- AND THEY
TOO ARE RECRUITED.
SHOW I I SEE THAT THERE ARE YOU
LEADING IN THAT DIRECTION THAT'S
WHY YOU CALL IN A PILOT PROGRAM
I DON'T WANT TO SHOOT IT DOWN.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SAY THIS IS
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST WOMEN.
BUT IF IT'S A DOOR OPENER FOR
THE FUTURE AND THAT'S WHY THE
PILOT THEN I CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT.
WOULD YOU COMMENT PLEASE.
YOUR DOCTOR DEFINITELY RIGHT
THIS IS -- WE'RE TRYING TO JUST
CONFORM WAS.
TO AND SEE DOUBLE THE RULES AND
RIGHT NOW DO YOU ONLY ADDRESSING
THE MALE BASKETBALL AFFLECK.
YOU KNOW AND AND TO NC DOUBLE A
RUSE.
THE IS REALLY DRIVEN BY THE
HUNDRED WHAT TWENTIES COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
IN A SHOW WORK WERE WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO CONFORM WITH A AND C.
W. YOU HAVE ANYTHING.
TO IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY ARE EXAMINING THE EXTENSION
TO THE WOMEN UNDER THE W. A. B.
AS WELL BECAUSE THEY FOLLOW THE
SAME CONTRACT.
SO THAT IS UNDER CONSIDERATION
YES SIR.
AND ALONG THIS PATH WITH THESE --
STUDENT ATHLETES BE RECEIVING
FUNDING MONIES -- PAYCHECKS BY
ANYWAYS.
FORM IN ADVANCE OF THEIR
FUTURISTIC PLAY.
YEAH THIS BILL ALLOWS THEM TO
HIRE AGENTS AND ALLOWS THE
AGENTS TO EXPEND MONEY -- IN THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS IT'S VERY
NARROW IT IT DOESN'T GET INTO
THE CONTRACTS THAT THE AGENTS
WILL THEN SIGN ON THE HALF OF
THE STUDENT ATHLETES AND THIS
DOES NOT -- ALLOW THE STUDENT
ATHLETES TO BECOME PROFESSIONALS
AS THEY MAINTAIN THEIR AMATEUR
STATUS SO IF THE START GETTING
PAID. TO PERFORM ATHLETICALLY --
THAT'S ANOTHER BILL.
AND AND AND THAT IS OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL THIS BILL
MERELY ALLOWS THEM. TO OBTAIN
THE SERVICE AGENTS AND IT ALLOWS
THE AGENTS TO EXPAND TO MINIMUS
AMOUNTS TRAVEL PART OF THE THE
ENTICEMENT TO SIGN WITH THE
AGENCY.
FOOD -- ASSOCIATED WITH -- WITH
THE CONTRACT SOLICITATIONS SO
IT'S IT'S NOT EXACTLY -- WITHIN
THE THE SCOPE OF US TO TO TALK
ABOUT THE THE PROFESSIONALISM.
GOOD THANK YOU.
I LET ME RECOGNIZE OUR VICE
CHAIR SENATOR CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
HAVING SOME HEART BURN OVER THE
FACT THAT WOMEN ARE BEING.
EXCLUDED -- I'M SORRY.
YEAH SO I DON'T KNOW HOLE IF --
IF.
YOU WOULD CONSIDER.
AMENDING YOUR BILL -- AGAIN THIS
IS NOT A BILL TO CHANGE OR AND
SEE DOUBLE THE RULING.
DOSES OF BAILED OUT WE'RE TRYING
TO CONFORM WITH WHAT IS ALREADY
BEING A SEPARATE AN NC DOUBLE A
I SHARE YOUR CONCERN TO YOU KNOW
A WHAT WOULD DEFINITELY WILL.
JOIN A LETTER TO NC DOUBLE A TO
ASK THEM.
TO A INCLUDE DIFFERENT SPORTS --
OF THE FOOTBALL L. O. YOU HAVE
READ TO JOIN YOU WITH A LETTER --
TO IN IN INCLUDE -- WELL WOMAN
TO AND BUT AGAIN THIS IS TO JUST.
TO WARM.
THE CALIFORNIA -- RULES WITH THE
NC DOUBLE THE RULES RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG A CENTER
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OUT I
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS AND I
THINK THAT MAYBE MY COLLEAGUES
THE CONCERNED ABOUT IT APPLYING
TO WOMEN WHICH OF COURSE WOULD
BE A CONCERN TO ME.
TOO THAT IS A DRESSED IN A BILL
THAT SENATOR SKINNER IS CARING
AND IS ON ITS WAY OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY SO I THINK THEY'RE TOO
EVEN THOUGH AND CA IS.
PART OF BOTH BILLS THIS IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THAT BILL
UNFORTUNATELY HER BILL --
ADDRESSES ANY CONCERNS WE HAVE
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WOMEN ARE
INCLUDED.
ALL BE HAPPY TO BE OF COSIGNED
AGO VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT -- ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OF
NOT ALLOWED THE AUTHOR CLOSE AND
WILL TAKE THE MATTER UP.
SOME THE NUMBER YOU WANT CLOSE
AGAIN DESERVES TO OF BUT
SOMETHING THAT CAME TO THE
REQUEST OVER OUR STATE
UNIVERSITIES.
AND IS WIDELY SUPPORTED BY THE A
HIGHER EDUCATION SACRAMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I I AM NOT SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD I THINK IT
IS NEARLY CRAFTED FOR A REASON.
THAT MEANT TO DISCRIMINATE AS I
KNOW YOU WOULD NOT WANT TO DO
AND IT FOR THAT REASON I WOULD
ENCOURAGE OUT MY COLLEAGUES TO
MOVE IT FORWARD AND I KNOW IT
HAS TO MORE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
OUR EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN OUR-JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THAT IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL.
CENTER LAY THAT MOVES THE BILL.
HAD HIM WITH THAT CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE GLAZER HI
LATER I CHANGED.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN.
WILK.
WILL GUY [inaudible] EIGHT ZERO
ALL RIGHT THAT THE BILL IS OUT --
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT I NOTICE OUR LAST AUTHOR
IS HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA IS
PRESENTING.
ITEM ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE ACT AS A
SUPERVISOR OF ASSOCIATE MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
ASSOCIATE CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS AND ASSOCIATE
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS.
WERE PROVIDING EDUCATIONALLY
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IN EDUCATIONAL AND CLINICAL
SETTINGS.
IT WOULD CHANGE THE STATUTORY
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE WHO
PROVISION.
OF ASSOCIATES TO ALLOW LICENSE
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGISTS TO
SUPERVISE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCE ASSOCIATES.
WERE PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN EDUCATIONAL AND CLINICAL
SETTINGS.
AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL ALLOW
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
pUP TO A MAXIMUM.
OF ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
HOURS WHILE THEY PROVIDE
SERVICES TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS.
TOWARDS LICENSOR.
THIS IS OUT OF THE TOTAL OF
THREE THOUSAND HOURS REQUIRED.
WOULD ALSO ALLOW.
LICENSE EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST
TO ENSURE THAT THE ASSOCIATES
ARE USING BEST PRACTICES WHEN
COUNSELING THESE STUDENTS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL ON WHAT KIND OF SERVICES
AND ACTIVITIES MAY BE SUPERVISED
BY A LICENSED EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
AND PROVIDE A DESCRIPTION OF
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND ADD THE DEFINITION OF
SUPERVISOR IN CODE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS.
AND LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS.
HERE TO TESTIFY.
THIS CHRISTOPHER JONES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST.
MR JOHNSON WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU THINK YOU ARE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME OF
OTHER COMMITTEE HERE.
ON CURRENTLY THE REGULATIONS NOT
ALLOW ELLIE PEAS AS MYSELF
LICENSE EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST --
TO PROVIDE SUPERVISION TO OTHER
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
ASSOCIATES -- OR PROFESSIONALS
GAINING HOURS TOWARDS THEIR
LICENSURE ON MANY OF THESE BBS
ASSOCIATES ARE EMPLOYED BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ON PROVIDING EDUCATIONALLY
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH IS THE EXPERTISE OF
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT NEED TO
EMPLOY OTHER BBS LICENSING IS TO
PROVIDE SUPERVISION FOR THE
ASSOCIATES EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY
NOT HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AS THEY RELATE
TO EDUCATIONAL.
FUNCTION.
IN ONE INSTANCE TO B. B. S.
ASSOCIATES WERE PROVIDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS IN A
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITY.
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF AN
ALLEY P. -- THEY BELIEVE THEIR
HOURS WOULD COUNT TOWARDS THEIR
LICENSURE -- BUT THEY WERE
DENIED THE ENTIRE YEARS WORK
WHICH WAS ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
HOURS -- BECAUSE THE SUPERVISION
WAS PROVIDED FINALLY P..
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO CHANGE THIS
AND ALLOW THE PEACE TO PROVIDE
SUPERVISION TO OTHER BBS
ASSOCIATES WHEN THEY'RE
PROVIDING SERVICES WITHIN OUR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE IN EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS.
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BBS ASSOCIATES
TO WORK TOWARDS THEIR THEIR
RELATED HOURS -- NEED HOURS FOR
LICENSURE WITH SUPERVISION
PROVIDED BY PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE EXPERTS IN EDUCATION RELATED.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES A MISTER
JOHNS ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
YES ROSEANNE HOMES REPRESENTING
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
OF THE BOARD HAD ORIGINALLY
TAKEN A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS LEGISLATION ON
ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS THAT
NARROWED -- THE HOURS AND ELLIE
P. MAY SUPERVISED TO
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
THE SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR HAVE
BEEN -- VERY RECEPTIVE TO THE
BOARD'S REQUESTS FOR AMENDMENTS
AND WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH US TO
GET. TO GET BE THE MOMENTS
DRAFTED AND THEY ARE NOW
INCLUDED IN THE BILL SO THE
BOARD HAS A SUPPORT POSITION --
THE BOARD BELIEVES THAT THE BILL
WILL HELP TO INCREASE SUPERVISED
EXPERIENCE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LICENSEES AND WILL ALSO INCREASE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUTURE LICENSEES SEEKING A
CAREER WORKING DOING THERAPY
WITH CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHURN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
BE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEE NOW WILL BE THE
BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
THE NINE THAT SELLING MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALRY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS
AREA HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THAT IS THAT I THINK THAT.
THE VICE CHAIR WHEELS AS WELL IS
THERE A MOTION.
SENATOR PAT HAS MOVED TO FILL.
CALL THE ROLL MISSION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GLAZER HI THERE I
CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
PARTULA AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN ALL RIGHT AND I
WILK RIGHT OKAY. NINE ZERO
REGULATIONS AS A NINE ZERO VOTE
IN FAVOR SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SELLING THEM.
OUR MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NEXT AND UP.
BEFORE I BRING UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THOSE WHO WERE LATE
ARRIVALS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HEARD THE IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT
BUT ARE WONDERFUL CONSULTANTS --
HUCKLE THIS IS HER LAST DAY WITH
US TODAY.
AND SHE SERVICE COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN A OUR AREA OF
EXPERTISE FOR MANY YEARS I'M I
HEAR IT'S THIRTEEN THE COULD BE
LONGER -- BUT SHE'S GOING
FORWARD TO DO SOME OTHER
EXCITING THINGS AND AND HER LIFE
BUT WE WANT TO THANK HER FOR HER
GREAT SERVICE TO ME.
SENATOR HILL IN MANY.
IN THE FUTURE IF I COULD JUST
ADD MY OF COURSE CONGRATULATIONS
FOR MOVING ON AND AND AND MIKE
THANKS FOR THE TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT.
THE TREMENDOUS I IN A WISDOM AND
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU BROUGHT TO
EVERY DISCUSSION EVERY
CONVERSATION AND EVERY BILL THAT
WE DEALT WITH HERE THAT IS IN
YOUR WITHIN YOUR PURVIEW AND AND
AND YOU'RE A REAL EXPERTISE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND WISHING
THAT THE WITH THE BEST.
SENATE HONORED IF THEY'RE ALL OF
YOU AND AND BOTH BODIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY.
WITH THAT HAPPY AND SAD MOMENTS --
HOLDER THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE'S THREE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS EIGHT
NINE AND TEN AS A MOTION BY
CENTER ARCHULETA TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THAT THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE TANK.
FIVE ARCHULETA VIRTUAL THAT AYE
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
WELL I LEYVA.
THEY'VE I'D PAN AYE PAN AYE WILK.
OKAY.
RIGHT THE CONSENT CALORIES BEEN
APPROVED NINE ZERO SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK NOW TO THE START
OF OUR AGENDA FOR THOSE WHO
MISSED -- ISSUES.
WE START WITH ITEM ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR OH FOUR BY -- MR STONE
IF THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING I WILK.
WILL GUIDE OUR THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO HOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NEXT TO ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS QUESTION IS DO PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
OCCURRED ABOUT.
SEVEN ZERO CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
READING I PAN.
AND I WILL -- IT WILL GUIDE AT
BILLS OUT. NINETY ZERO ONE NEXT
MOVE TO ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVEN THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR WHEN THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
MOTION AS DO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CORRECT BUT SEVEN ZERO VICE
CHAIR READING I'D PAN.
CAN I WILK WILL GUIDE.
ALL RIGHT THAT FILLS OUT -- NINE
ZERO AND THAT COMPLETES THE
BUSINESS OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ALL FOR
ATTENDING OR LISTENING IN AND
WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED